so und Philipp deine Welt ist die
Meinung ja also Deutschland zu dieser
Stunde am meisten auf ich weiß nicht ob
Deutschland sich einer Sache schon
bewusst geworden ist ich habe das
zumindest von der CDU bislang noch nicht
gehört man spricht schon jetzt über eine
mögliche Regierungsbildung will ins
Kanzleramt einziehen aber ich glaube den
Menschen ist noch nicht ganz klar
geworden was eine cdu-niederlage in
Teilen des Landes wirklich bedeuteten
vor allem wenn man mal in den Osten
schaut ich würde gerne mal einmal meinen
Laptop umdrehen da sieht man nämlich die
Wahlkreise in Sachsen die erst Stimmen
in Sachsen und diese Karte ist blau und
blau ist die AFD das ist eine
rechtsextremer Partei die in Sachsen
davon profitiert massiv davon profitiert
dass sie die CDU komplett abschmiert das
haben die Menschen in Sachsen das haben
ganz Deutschland der CDU zu verdanken
und federführend natürlich Armin Laschet
das gäbe ist ansonsten nicht das Land
ist eigentlich tief schwarz da hat
eigentlich Michael Kretschmer der
Ministerpräsident letztes mal noch
relativ souverän die Wahl gewonnen und
dieses Land ist jetzt AFD blau bei den
Zweitstimmen liegt die CDU in Sachsen
auf Platz 3 nach der SPD nach der AFD
das ist grauenvoll und diese Folgen die
wird man eigentlich noch aufarbeiten
müssen hoffe ich zumindest danke für
diesen wichtigen Blick auch eine ganz
wichtige Erzählung
danke geworden
[Musik]